[Music]
welcome to the annual Kendall lecture in
association with this lecture one of the
things we do is award the MIT global
habitability award and here to talk a
little bit about the award is mr. Fred
Middleton who's sponsoring the award and
Fred graduated from MIT in 1971 with a
degree in chemistry and then has a
Harvard MBA which he received in 1973 he
was a consultant with McKinsey in San
Francisco after graduation and then he
and his college roommate found it the
gene tech incorporated which is a
biotech company based in South San
Francisco and he served as a vice
president of corporate development and
the CFO there and he is now founder and
managing director of Sanderling ventures
which is a biomedical venture capital
firm based in San Mateo California since
1987 where they work with start-up
companies established to develop
advances in biomedical technologies he
lives in Hillsborough California with
his wife and three children and we're
happy to welcome Fred here to say a
little bit about the award thank you
[Applause]
thanks Maria and I will be brief the
global habitat habitability award was
started you know with the intention of
recognizing students faculty members or
anyone in the MIT community you know
contributing to the knowledge of our
global habitat and the sustainability of
it over time and part of the reason
being you know that my belief is that
you know the kind of quality science and
work done at MIT and in this department
in particular has an opportunity to
enlighten you know the rest of the world
and in particular you know public policy
about these issues and you know I think
we're at the point where you know there
hasn't really been yet an enlightened
public policy formed around these issues
and I think it's the role of science and
the MIT community to assist the rest of
us in providing you know the knowledge
and information about environmental
trends affecting the habitats and the
sort of public policy you know that
would be enlightened to deal with it in
the future so that's my thinking behind
making this award
[Applause]
okay this year's a recipient of the
award is is Mick follows and
unfortunately Mick isn't here today
because he's interviewing for a faculty
position so this award could not have
come at a better time for him but let me
just tell you a little bit about what he
did to merit this award make is a
principal research scientist in eeap's
and the work that he did is study of
mechanisms that control the flux of
carbon dioxide between the atmosphere
and ocean and this work has been
published in a series of papers in the
last couple of years and in this work
Mick combines a deep knowledge of the
biogeochemistry of the ocean with with
an understanding of fluid mechanics and
what he has been able to do is develop
models that describe the factors that
control the air sea flux of co2 and
other soluble gases and he's been able
to distill the essence of a very
complicated process and and express it
in simple models that actually come up
with hard numbers that can and are being
tested against observations so we
congratulate Mick there's an award that
goes with this and when he gets back we
will give it to him but he is delighted
and asked me to express his appreciation
to to Fred for this award and now Ron
Prinn will introduce the candle speaker
certainly let me add my congratulations
to Mick follows for winning this award
by the way it's worth 25 thousand I
don't know why and people are not
mentioning sir pending on who you are
that's a lot of money for Mick it's a
lot of money so I'm sure he I know he's
very very pleased it's my distinct
pleasure to introduce the Henry Kendall
lecture but before doing so I want to
say a little bit about Henry Kendall
himself Henry of course was a Nobel
laureate and physics and particle
physics and a very remarkable scientist
but this
lecture does not memorialize his
nobel-prize-winning our work but rather
the work that he did particularly within
the Union of Concerned Scientists about
the global environment and great concern
for what human activity might do to the
environment both now and and going into
the future and one of the things that I
hope you picked up as you came in was
was this little brochure that is is a
copy of the 1992 declaration that was
sponsored by the Union of Concerned
Scientists it's called world scientists
warning to humanity the text was very
much the work of Henry and certainly
championed by him and it was signed by a
very large number of people including
104 Nobel laureates and just you can
read it at your leisure but in reading
it it gives you a sense of the deep
concern that Henry had for the
environment I always remember that when
the center for global change science was
set up and I was just moving into some
offices in the 13th floor and I had on
old clothes and I was covered with dust
lugging stuff from the 18th to the 13th
floor that he rushed in and I wonder I
thought he was lost I knew who he was
and he said this is a wonderful event
that you guys have you know finally you
know worrying about global change and so
on so we had a really nice long
conversation and I was most impressed
with the fact that when you talk to him
he is a very ordinary guy he just walked
in the room and as I said I thought he
was lost and then he he really had come
for some particular reason so a
wonderful person and this is a wonderful
memorial to him now it's my distinct
pleasure to introduce the sixth annual
Henry Kendall lecture it is dr. Jerry
Malala who got his bachelor's and
master's degrees at Wesleyan University
in 1965 and 1968 he then went on to Yale
and got a master's degree in forestry
and then followed by a PhD that was in
72 and 77
he in 19 is 67 beginning in 1967 is that
right you joined the ecosystem center or
was at the 70s 77 76 that's it 1976
Gerry joined the ecosystem center at the
marine biology lab in Woods Hole and by
1988 he was a director of the ecosystem
Center and he is now co-director of that
Center and has been ever since that time
and so he's really been in one place
most of the time however he did take
some trips to Washington where he did
some very influential things first
he was director of NSF SEC of system
study program from 1986 to 1988 and then
in the 1996 to 1997 he was associate
director for environment in the Office
of the President and played a lot of
role in in the Clinton administration in
in helping formulate policy in global
change issues he's very well known for
his scientific leadership to just give a
few examples he was chair the u.s.
United States Scientific Committee on
problems of the environment that's known
as scope to those of us in the
environmental area and a very important
committee he then became vice chair of
the International global dear Co
biosphere programme headquartered in
Sweden Neil and later became president
of scope itself international scope and
he's now president-elect and may be
about to become president of the
Ecological Society of America Gerry has
won many honors including most recently
he was elected to the American
Philosophical Society
I've known Gerry myself for perhaps 17
or 18 years beginning with the into the
I G BP experience and we shared many
interesting discussions and it was in
1991 1990
to that we approached Jerry to see if he
would join the Global Change joint
program at MIT because we desperately
needed some echo system expertise and
the great thing is that he has he joined
us and we enjoy many many joint projects
so with that as an introduction we are
indeed privileged to have such an expert
in echo systems to speak to us today his
topic is changes in the land
environmental stresses and the
terrestrial biosphere is capacity to
store carbon Thank You Jerry Ron I want
to join you and congratulating Mick on
that award and now that I know there's
money attached to it I'm expecting to
see some very fancy vests those of you
who know him Ron I want to thank you for
the invitation to speak in the Kendall
lecture series
I knew Henry Kendall as a sailor first a
brilliant scientist and a citizen
committed to using science for the
benefit of society I'm delighted to
continue my association with him in my
mind as I talk with you today
see if I can make the technology work at
the end of junior McNeil's something new
Under the Sun an environmental history
the 20th century world title the measure
of the 20th century many of the two
dozen entries in the table are related
to either fossil fuel burning or land
use the two primary drivers of changes
in the global carbon cycle recognition
of the humans capacity to alter the
planets carbon cycle has to be one of
the major accomplishments of Earth
System science during the last century
our challenge for this century is to
understand the global carbon cycle well
enough to manage it to promote human
wellbeing while protecting the biosphere
and it's life support functions now in
this slide is the book cover from McNeil
and he has reproduced diego rivera´s
painting man controller of the universe
if you ever get a chance look at it very
closely there are lots of people that
you would recognize through history
represented in that painting and it
reminds us of the difficulties humans
encounter when they try to manage
complex systems the message is proceed
with caution today I want to give you a
terrestrial ecologist perspective on the
global carbon cycle with a particular
focus on the factors controlling carbon
storage in the mosaic of ecosystems that
make up the biosphere what are these
factors how are they functioning
currently and how do we expect them to
function in the future answers to these
questions should help us to think about
how best to manage the global carbon
cycle in the coming decades I've divided
my talk into four parts I'll begin with
a quick review of the global carbon
cycle but as I look out at this audience
I'm not sure that that was necessary and
I'll stress the role of land ecosystems
second I will discuss the factors
controlling carbon storage in
terrestrial ecosystems and their
relative importance in recent decades
next I will pay special attention to
regional regional scale carbon cycling I
will give you my understanding of how
the controller's of carbon storage
varium in importance from region to
region in the last part of my talk I
will give you my thoughts about the
potential for carbon storage and
terrestrial ecosystems over the 21st
century here I will consider both
natural and managed systems now I think
we all know that over the past 200 years
humans have introduced about 400
petagrams of carbon into the atmosphere
through deforestation and the burning of
fossil fuels the oceans in terrestrial
biosphere have absorbed part of this
carbon with the remainder accumulate
in the atmosphere numerous pathways as
shown in this side connect the land
atmosphere ocean system the dynamic
behavior of this system is determined by
the relative sizes of the different
reservoirs and fluxes together with the
biogeochemical processes and human
driving forces controlling the exchanges
now this cartoon which actually comes
from a scope volume produced in a garden
spot Ubbe to Bob Raziel and Ron was
forced to spend one full week there as
part of this activity notes the sizes of
the major pools and fluxes the
human-driven fluxes and pools are
outlined in red and the natural fluxes
are in black let me focus on a couple of
I've got it right here and it's green so
I think we're gonna be in good shape let
me focus on a couple of the fluxes this
is the natural flux between the land and
the atmosphere and just let me define
two terms that term NPP which stands for
net primary production and it is the net
amount of carbon transformed into
biomass per unit time by plants and the
unit of time normally is a year and so
this flux represents 57 petagrams of
carbon captured by plants on net during
the course of the year and most of that
carbon is emitted back to the atmosphere
through either respiration or fires
ocean fluxes are also large relative to
the human dominated fluxes and I want to
point out two of the human dominated
fluxes that we're going to be talking
about one is land-use change and right
now the estimates of land-use change
approximately a pedigree of carbon per
year 1.2 in this diagram and this other
term the land sink which is the uptake
of carbon across the landscape and we'll
talk about where in a minute
by vegetation of all kinds these fluxes
that are represented here are averages
for the 1980s in the 1990s this is a
fairly full table and I'll try to focus
your mind on just a couple of parts of
it carbon storage and fluxes vary by
major vegetation associations which we
call biomes tropical forests contain the
largest plant carbon pool and they are
the most productive that is again
annually they produce the most plant
biomass interestingly tropical forests
also contain the largest soil carbon
pool and this is something that people
hadn't recognized for many years and
only recently have we been stressing
this particular point in the global
carbon cycle now the tropical forest
plant pool is being diminished by
deforestation and this is a prominent
feature of the part of the contemporary
carbon budget driven by human actions
and I'll come back to this again and
again forest clearing in the tropics is
estimated as we saw in the previous
slide to be releasing about one peda
gram of carbon per year to the
atmosphere parenthetically I should tell
you that this flux is not well
understood and could easily be off by at
least 50%
in either direction the uncertainty
dries from two major sources first
estimates of the area cleared each year
and second the mass of the vegetation
that is being cleared a couple of other
things I'd like you to notice about this
particular table one of them is that
the temperate whoops sorry wrong button
the temperate for us represented in this
row contain large stocks of both plant
and soil carbon and in fact in the
global context or the second largest
carbon pool in the terrestrial biosphere
and third are the boreal forests the
take-home message here is that forests
are important in the global carbon cycle
yes the the exchange in one direction or
another I'm sorry the other thing to
look at is this row right here this row
tells us something about in this last
column the store of carbon frozen in
high latitude soils it is very large and
in a warming world potentially quite
vulnerable to decay the decay would
result in either carbon dioxide
emissions to the atmosphere or methane
emissions to the atmosphere depending
upon whether it takes place under
aerobic or anaerobic conditions so this
is sort of background information I'd
like you to keep in mind as we talk
through again the key points forests are
important tropical forests are the major
storehouse of carbon in the terrestrial
biosphere and frozen soils contain a
vast pool of carbon that is potentially
vulnerable in a warming world to
decomposition and flux back to the
atmosphere now a less busy cartoon early
21st century look at the major fluxes
among the carbon pools
we have fossil fuel-burning releasing
now over 6.5 petagrams of carbon to the
atmosphere forest clearing estimated to
release another one so that's 7.5
petagrams of carbon i put into the
atmosphere 3.5 of the 7.5 remain and the
oceans and the land take up the
remainder it's also important to keep in
mind now this is a cartoon as I
mentioned because there's tremendous
inter annual variability in these fluxes
and this is represented by this graphic
that was copied from Sarmiento & Gruber
and then updated a bit it illustrates
the inter-annual variability in the
uptake very well in the dark blue at the
bottom we have accumulation rate of
carbon in the atmosphere and the units
are petagrams of carbon per year and it
looks like a cityscape and in green we
have the accumulation of carbon in
oceans and land not differentiated just
oceans plus land and the point is that
the amount of carbon accumulated in the
ocean in the linen and land varies
substantially year-to-year and we'll
talk about this a little more later on
the main inter annual feature of the
record is clearly correlated with
climatic variations such as the El Nino
Southern Oscillation or major climate
anomalies such as the Pinatubo eruption
however the variability does not seem to
be equally distributed and terrestrial
ecosystems seem to be the culprits in
the variability picture rather than the
oceans
now back to this cartoon again and it's
the last time you'll see it I want to
focus on this land sink term the
terrestrial uptake term and there are
basically two questions of interests
that I'm going to talk about the first
is where is the carbon sequestration
occurring with the capacity to store
large amounts of carbon in wood forests
are considered important candidates for
storage but which for us are we talking
about the boreal forests of Eurasia the
temperate forests of the mid latitudes
or the tropical forests in Latin America
Southeast Asia and Africa perhaps the
answer is all of them we'll come back to
this the second question to keep in mind
is what factors are affecting the net
uptake of carbon in any region and I
list here a set of candidates climate
change changes in land use co2
fertilization this is the stimulation of
photosynthesis by elevated
concentrations of carbon dioxide
nitrogen fertilization and here I mean
inadvertent fertilization nitrogen
deposited on terrestrial ecosystems in
rainfall and in this place each year
about nine kilograms of nitrogen per
hectare rains on the city and so
basically we're sort of UTRA flying
across the landscape with nitrogen the
final candidate is ozone pollution in
ozone pollution operates to diminish the
capacity of plants to take up carbon
through photosynthesis so we have some
things that are going to benefit
or enhance carbon uptake they include
certainly co2 fertilization and nitrogen
inputs and several two things that
definitely are going to cause releases
under some circumstances changes in land
use and ozone pollution and then climate
change which can do a variety of things
and we'll talk about those also now
approaches to estimating the fluxes
between the land and the atmosphere
there are four major approaches which
I've listed here
atmospheric inversion modeling and Ron
and his group have expertise in that
area process based surface modeling
which attempts to build from detailed
process understanding of ecosystems to
flux estimates extrapolations of in
situations such as time series
measurements of tree growth across large
areas and then trying to extrapolate the
either carbon accumulation or release as
a result of those studies and finally
carbon cycle tracer studies include
isotopes of carbon oxygen and nitrogen
in very creative ways now first of all
to the inversion studies this is a
summary slide of a comparison of 16
inversion models and model variants the
data show the annual mean latitudinal
ocean land distribution of non fossil
fuel carbon sources and sinks for the
five-year period between 1992 and 1996
it's a bit of a busy graph that very
informative the boxes represent AA
priori fluxes and uncertainties as big
green and blue boxes the crosses are the
inferred mean fluxes so that these
here are the inferred mean fluxes for
those latitudinal bands and the vertical
bar as an open circle show the between
model and within model uncertainties the
thing to note here I've pointed to in
red right here and that is that the
northern hemisphere estimates exhibit
substantial co2 uptake on land so if
we're looking for contemporary carbon
sinks
we want to look at the land ecosystems
of the northern hemisphere by the way
the sine conversion here is the
atmospheric scientist in relative to the
atmosphere I'll change that convention a
little later on and I will remind you
that I'm doing it while the inversion
model approach can provide insights into
the distribution of source sink behavior
on large latitudinal bands they do not
provide understanding of the mechanisms
responsible for the fluxes for the past
decade a small but growing number of
research teams including my own have
been using process based surface
modeling to address the issue of
mechanisms we've been told where to look
and now we're going to try to look
carefully and that's going to be much of
the message of this part of the talk now
we developed a very simple model in our
group in several of my grouper here Dave
kicked ladder and Ben fell sir
and they do Yeomans work and provide
tremendous input to this activity these
process based models are spatially
referenced ours is as well and they use
information on climate elevation soils
vegetation and water availability to
make monthly estimates of vegetation and
soil carbon and nitrogen fluxes in pools
we run the model at a variety of spatial
Lucian's but the one I will talk about
today is 1/2 degree by 1/2 degree
approximately 50 kilometers on a side at
the equator although in the modeling
activity we carry along sub grid square
or pixel information so that we can
provide some insight this is a reduced
form model but one of the important
things I want you to notice is that it
contains both descriptions of what is
happening to carbon and nitrogen in
terrestrial ecosystems this is important
I think in modeling global climate
change because the carbon and nitrogen
cycles are intimately coupled in many
ways and very often the carbon cycle
rate is limited by the availability of
nitrogen in terrestrial ecosystems of
the high latitudes including the
ecosystems that we have outside here
especially the forest systems let me
show you why one might want to think
about carbon and nitrogen together in a
model that is trying to think about
carbon storage simple question will the
warming of soils increase or decrease
the net amount of carbon stored in a
land ecosystem and I've put up here on
this little diagram some of the things
that we think happen when soils are
warmed on the left-hand side of the
diagram point to soil warming leading to
increased microbial activity and
increased respiration on the right-hand
side of the diagram I point to two other
things that can happen one is the
lengthening of the growing season and
the second and perhaps the most
important is the increasing of the
availability of nitrogen
the reason this happens is that soil
organic matter contains both carbon and
nitrogen as the carbon is processed and
leaves the system as carbon dioxide the
nitrogen remains behind is no longer
organically bound and is in either an
ammonium form or a nitrate form easily
taken up by the plants so you want to
keep all of this in mind when you're
thinking about what warming of soil is
going to mean for net carbon balance in
an ecosystem two possibilities if we
have increased microbial respiration as
the dominant response we're going to
enhance the fluxes of carbon from the
soil to the atmosphere and on net if
that is the dominant response the system
will lose carbon if however increased
nitrogen availability stimulates plant
growth and the accumulation of carbon in
the growing plants and if that is a
dominant process we would have net
accumulation in the ecosystem although
we would have some carbon loss from the
soils is that clear does that make sense
so we set up an experiment at the
Harvard forest to test these simple
ideas this is about 70 miles to the west
of here and Peter Sam Massachusetts
we're working in a mixed deciduous
forest and we are warming the soils with
three and a half miles of heating cable
the technology is the same technology
that they use it Mile High Stadium in
Denver to be able to play football
during the middle of the winter we call
them and they told us about how they did
it and they said what are you doing and
we tell them what we were doing and the
guy couldn't believe it he calls several
people to the phone and he said would
you repeat that and so there we are but
we've been doing this kind of work for a
number of years at the Harvard forest
and the results have been interesting
initially we had relatively small plots
of five by five meters and some of the
trees were in and some of the trees were
out and it wasn't very satisfactory
but it was a deal made with the devil
because we couldn't get funding unless
we had lots of replication and there was
an agricultural split plot design in
somebody's mind that we had to conform
to but later on as the first set of
results came out and we published them
in 2002 and December in science we got
additional funding to do a very large
plot so we now a big 30 by 30 meter plot
with lots of trees in it and lots of
heating cable and the bills are becoming
astronomical and we're probably part of
the problem not part of the solution
this is what we found this is the set of
results that we have after four years of
study and let me tell you from the
original study we found that there was a
period of time actually six years when
the soils were basically pumping out
carbon at the rate of about almost a
metric ton per hectare per year and then
through time out to 15 years that
dropped off and at the end of about 12
years actually there was really no
difference between the heated and
control plots well here we've been
running this large experiment for four
years and the results are as follows we
see substantial loss of carbon from the
soils not 90 grams per meter squared or
900 kilograms per hectare coming out of
the soil on net each year in response to
warming this is the Delta
however the trees are also growing
faster and accumulating carbon in their
wood and after four years we've
accumulated on an annual basis a little
more than 50 percent of the carbon being
lost from the soils now if the pattern
that we saw before follows then
eventually we're going to see that flux
of carbon from the soil to the
atmosphere winding down to zero and we
think it's because we're exhausting a
relatively labile pool of carbon in the
soils and we're going to see this
vegetation accumulation of carbon
continued because one of the things that
we noticed in the earlier experiment is
that once you make some nitrogen
available to the rapidly cycling portion
of the nitrogen cycle in a forest it
stays there for a long time and each
spin of the cycle puts a little in the
wood and puts a little in new
recalcitrant organic matter and the
stoichiometry of the system is such that
the c2n ratio in the soils in the upper
30 centimeters or so is 30 to one and
the C to end ratio in wood is three
hundred to one so if you can move one
mass unit of nitrogen from the soil to
the trees you get a big carbon benefit
and we calculated that all we had to do
is move about 10% of the accelerated
nitrogen cycle into the trees each year
to account for the carbon uptake so it's
really sort of a a marginal benefit that
pays big dividends in the long term
nonetheless if you don't have both
carbon and nitrogen in your model you
would never be able to predict this
particular behavior of terrestrial
ecosystems the other reason for having
carbon in both carbon and nitrogen in a
model is related to co2 fertilization
and I'll come back to this but I want to
want to say that temperate boreal and
very high latitude ecosystems are
basically their plant productivity is
basically limited by nitrogen you can
put all the co2 in the world on those
systems and they will be minimally
responsive unless you alleviate the
nitrogen limitation warming in it's
perverse way has a chance of alleviating
some of that nitrogen limitation and so
you need both carbon and nitrogen and my
last point is that most of the models of
the terrestrial biosphere are currently
being used for example in IPCC or Carbon
only
models this is a problem okay now we
attempt to validate our modeling
activity in a variety of ways some of
the bars I have to admit are very low
but we're continually working at it and
we work on validation across scales in
space and time from the Eddy flux towers
at the Harvard forest run by Steve Wasi
and bill monger here to the in model
inversions that Ron and his colleagues
are doing and in a variety of things in
between including forest inventories and
we've worked with forest inventories in
the US and also in the tropics in a very
interesting process
now in addition to the modeling
activities I've already shown you one
experiment but we actually attempt to
conduct experiments across the globe
testing hypotheses that are generated by
the model and I have three examples here
these are done by my colleagues at the
ecosystem center the first one on the
top is a manipulation of land use in the
Brazilian Amazon and that's the project
of mine where we've manipulated many
tens of hectares looking at different
kinds of management practices to
evaluate the capacity of these systems
to store carbon this is in the state of
Rondonia the top picture and the area is
was originally tropical forest cleared
in the 70s 80s and in the early 90s
converted into pasture the c3 tropical
trees were replaced by c4 african
grasses that are highly productive in
this area and support reasonable
stocking levels of cattle after a
pasture is in place for a decade or so
it begins to become less productive and
less capable of supporting the animals
and so one of the things that the
farmers are doing is testing different
techniques of
rejuvenating the productivity of those
pastors to make them better suited for
grazing cattle and so they've got all
kinds of schemes that involve the the
planting of rice and cotton inter crops
different fertilization schemes and so
on and we're trying to test some of
those and look at the consequences for
carbon stocks and having the advantage
of stable isotopes stable carbon
isotopes being different between the c3
vegetation and the c-4 vegetation helps
us quite a bit that picture there is a
picture of the original soil warming
project at the Harvard forest in the
early spring and you can see that we've
moved snowmelt out about two weeks early
in this particular picture so all of the
heated plots are the ones where there is
no snow cover and this study here is in
the Alaskan High Arctic north of the
Brooks Range where we're looking at the
effects of warming in in these
greenhouses and the additions of
nitrogen on the structure of these
ecosystems and this is a worn and
fertilized system that has a tremendous
amount of woody vegetation growth
relative to the surrounding area and
this kind of change which is probably
many decades down the road in the real
systems in the Arctic could have
implications for albedo and climate
warming etc so we try to combine
experiments with our modeling constantly
testing the hypotheses that we're
generating now this is a again a cartoon
of our of our model running at have to
be by 1/2 degree spatial scale monthly
timescale and we use a series of using
sure
that these the experiments are to look
at the effects of a variety of
agricultural practices on carbon storage
in the soils of these systems and and
these are common practices that are
being put in place and we're trying to
measure the consequences for
biogeochemist chemical processes
including carbon storage trace gas
fluxes leaching of nutrients to the
groundwater and so on okay yep
I think we'll keep the questions heating
cable under the under the soil yeah okay
I guess that's the convention so I'm
gonna gonna move ahead so this is a
listing of the model inputs and some of
the outputs the inputs include
temperature precipitation solar
radiation atmospheric co2 concentration
land cover and land use nitrogen
deposition and ozone and these are
dynamic features that change over time
the static features our elevation in
soil type and then the outputs include a
whole array of biogeochemical parameters
many of which are relevant to global
global carbon cycle research now I want
to move to some studies that we've been
conducting at the regional scale using
this modeling approach and we've
actually worked in two regions quite
intensively one is China and the other
is the coterminous us and our question
was how do the different drivers of
carbon storage that I listed earlier
operate in those two places now in order
to run the models in each of the places
we have to have background information
and this graphic shows land-use change
over the 1990s in China based on
repeated analyses of Landsat images
taken over that time
it's a wall-to-wall analysis and it's an
incredible data set that Professor Liu
who was the Chinese Academy of Sciences
and his team produced with the help of
our group in the US and there are some
transitions shown here that are really
quite revealing changes of importance
for the carbon cycle for example
would be woodland to cropland grassland
to cropland and the expansion of urban
areas the resolution here is one
kilometer on a side degraded to ten
kilometers for security reasons by the
Chinese and I want you to notice the the
bay high corridor the Beijing to
Shanghai corridor that red arc that
moves down the expansion of urban areas
and this is occurring in this ancient
landscape at a breakneck pace in any of
you who have been to China recently will
agree that building takes place 24 hours
a day every day of the week 365 days a
year so it's it's possible to imagine
that this is happening and Landsat
doesn't lie as they say a couple of
things I'd like you to notice this
business of grassland of cropland this
is one of the biggest changes that is
occurring in China these days where
grasslands are being plowed up and
turned into croplands in the north of
China at quite a rapid rate and there is
also some woodland conversion to
cropland although the Chinese are trying
to reforest areas especially degraded
areas that have a high probability of
erosion but this data set is really a
treasure and it will allow us identity
to do some very interesting land-use
analyses in China now here is an
application of our model trying to
ascribe either carbons sync function or
carbon source function relative to the
land for the major drivers we talked
about earlier climate co2 fertilization
tropospheric ozone land-use change and
they are represented in the different
colors and what we have here is a
cumulative effect of the various factors
on carbon storage
the ecosystems of China over the 20th
century and the black line represents
the net change relative to 1900 so when
the slope is negative the system is
losing that is all of China is losing
carbon from the land and when it is
positive it is gaining carbon most of
the century in China was basically a
carbon loss phenomenon it's only in the
last two decades that the net carbon
balance of China is positive several
other things to notice land-use change
is a major player in the carbon dynamics
of this system co2 fertilization is a
positive force for carbon storage and
tropospheric ozone is playing an
increasingly important role in carbon
storage in China reducing plant
productivity and reducing the capacity
of plants to add carbon to the soils and
to themselves and and store it for long
periods of time just a couple of things
to point out I wanted to point out the
decade of the Great Leap Forward 1950 to
1959 a lot of deforestation in China to
fuel the the smelters the backyard
smelters the biggest net carbon lost
year from land to the atmosphere
negative carbon storage on the land the
biggest decade was 1920s and on net over
the entire century according to our
model simulations China lost 4.7
petagrams from the land to the
atmosphere same kind of analysis for the
US again the same drivers being
considered again land use a major player
nitrogen deposition in the u.s. a more
important phenomenon than in China
according to our simulations in terms of
promoting carbon storage and
tropospheric ozone appearing to become
more and more important over the 20th
century in the u.s. we have almost a
zero net flux from the land to the
atmosphere although over time there were
decades of quite substantial flux a
1920s 1929 large forestry activities in
the West agriculture opening up in
places and causing tremendous amounts of
carbon to be lost from soils as a
consequence of plowing and so on the co2
fertilization question I want to come
back to that we have tried to use data
from places like the Duke forests where
they're doing these open co2
fertilization experiments in forest
ecosystems and one of the things that
the Duke Forest is shown in their
experiments is that there are
differences in the ability of co2
fertilization to stimulate carbon
storage and ecosystems depending upon
the availability of nitrogen and they
have natural nitrogen availability
gradients across this set of circular
free air circulation installations and
the clear message that comes from them
is that nitrogen availability is
critical back to the point that you want
to have a model that deals with both
nitrogen and carbon nitrogen however is
a two-edged sword well it may stimulate
carbon storage it can cascade through
ecosystems and cause tremendous problems
of eutrophication of water systems for
example as well as create public health
problems this is a data slide from
Chesapeake Bay midsummer showing low
oxygen oxygen conditions in red at the
top of the bay and higher oxygen below
the circles have to do with fish catch
the point is that this is a serious
problem the nitrogen loading problem and
this eutrophication is largely the
result of nitrogen loading a serious
problem in estuaries all across the
world and so while nitrogen deposition
may enhance plant growth on land it can
create tremendous problems in water
systems and if the nitrogen deposition
is excessive on the land
it can cause dieback of vegetation as
well now I want to move to the globe
very quickly I'm well behind here but I
just wanted to say that as Ron pointed
out we've been working with the MIT
global change program for the last
decade and we've tried to work within
the framework where possible deriving
climate change scenarios for the future
atmospheric chemistry composition etc
generated from a series of economic
scenarios deriving from the EPEL
modeling activity as part of the MIT
integrated program and I just want to
show you the results of one experiment
that we did that is a policy-related
experiment and basically we asked the
question how important is it do we think
to cap ozone at current levels for
maintaining or increasing carbon storage
on the land and this is some of the work
of Ben felzer and just a couple of quick
things about this experiment the
experiment was run for the entire Center
when T first century the carbon
emissions resulted in an end of the
century carbon concentration in the
atmosphere of about 800 parts per
million and the temperature increase
associated with the carbon dioxide
increase was estimated to be about 3
degrees C in
so here is first of all down at the
bottom the consequence of having an
ozone policy in place and the idea is
that with an ozone policy in place over
the century with co2 temperature and
ozone as drivers in this particular case
we held nitrogen and land use constant
we see an increase in carbon storage on
the land over the century with an ozone
cap of about 180 petagrams that is about
the same amount of carbon stored over
the 21st century as was released due to
land use activities from the 1700s to
the present so it's it's a large large
number and potentially quite significant
without the cap the increase is at least
20 percent less at least 20 percent less
we have a whole bunch of variants as to
how we treat agricultural lands and so
on but the point is that if you don't
cap ozone pollution you can diminish by
a significant amount carbon storage in
terrestrial ecosystems according to our
simulation now moving quickly as I think
about the 21st century however land use
has to be the major issue for us and
this is an article that appeared in The
New York Times on the 29th of April the
title forests in Southeast Asia fall to
prosperity Zack's is a very interesting
title it has to do with large Chinese
investment in Borneo to convert tropical
rainforests into palm oil plantations
and the palm oil will be used for
biodiesel so they're working on the
carbon problem I guess and climate
change the investment is large it's 7
billion dollars in 2005 and this and
other investments have resulted in
clearing of half of the forests in
Borneo
this is what this the sequence would
look like starting with the large
diptych carp forests of Borneo over to
your left the clearing down at the
bottom in the resulting palm oil for us
you are going to reduce in a very
substantial way the biomass per hectare
on the land that is converted from
tropical forests to palm oil plantation
no question about it these are large
losses will not be replaced and so when
you're doing your long term carbon
accounting we have to think about that
Brazil the area of Brazil that I work in
rondônia and mato grosso up in the upper
left an aerial picture of tropical
forests in southern Rondonia the
clearing of those forests and also the
clearing of Serato here that is savanna
and the planting down here of soybean
soybean is being used as a food stock
being sold abroad largely to China by
the way and it is also being used now to
generate biodiesel for the Brazilian
economy so lots of this kind of activity
going on back to Brazil again and I
don't mean to pick on Brazil in fact the
Brazilians have some of the best records
of deforestation that we have for the
world the government is clearly
concerned there are a set of regulations
there trying to figure out how to move
forward in the land use area and they're
very aware of the carbon cycle
implications because I work with a
number of the scientists there this is a
table that lists the deforestation
record
from the late 70s to 2004 just look at
2004 for a second area cleared a little
over 10,000 square miles the size of the
state of Massachusetts
wall-to-wall total area cleared about
70% of the state of Texas if you've ever
driven across Texas it takes a long time
this is this is a large large area and
so the prospects for carbon storage if
this kind of activity on land if this
kind of activity were to continue is not
a pretty picture I'm getting near the
end now and I want to talk about three
things in the models that we run we can
simulate with I think some degree of
confidence a number of things maybe the
the best is and the easiest thing to
simulate is the consequence of of
land-use change if you know what it is
but there are complexities and surprises
that we want to think about and I have
three quick examples biogeochemical
feedbacks and this is a picture of the
pan Arctic and I just want to point out
permafrost thawing remember 800 peda
gram or 400 petagrams of carbon sitting
in frozen state if it unfreezes to
potential consequences either large
amounts of co2 entering the atmosphere
or large amounts of methane or a
combination depending upon soil moisture
conditions important biochemical
feedback to keep in mind and to
incorporate in forward modeling
disturbances not human driven land-use
change so much as wild fires in places
like the boreal forests they're a
dominant feature of the boil for us
today but the question is how will
climate change change the rate and the
the fires in the future a lot of people
who work in the boreal forest are now
arguing that there could be a doubling
in the rate of fires and this could be
very significant in a negative way for
carbon storage on the land and finally
threshold responses and this is a
cartoon describing the the first I think
fully coupled model land atmosphere
ocean model from the Hadley center that
looked at climate change in the future
and one of the things that their model
projected was the drying out of areas
especially in the tropics and and
ultimately the conversion of the Amazon
basin as a consequence of so water
limitations from a forest predominately
a forest to predominately a savanna and
the consequent loss of tremendous
amounts of carbon stocks these are the
kinds of things these threshold
responses that are particularly
difficult to deal with but things we
have to keep in mind okay I want to sum
up here very quickly and in talk about
my look into a very clouded crystal ball
and I see the best case as being what I
have put up on the board and I'll catch
up with myself a second here the best
case is a small amount of carbon
additional carbon storage in land
ecosystems in the 21st century let me
break it down to those drivers that I
was talking about I think that the
combined effects of climate change and
co2 fertilization
will lead to a modest increase in
terrestrial carbon stocks of about 200
petagrams on the plus side that was very
close to that hundred eighty pentagram
number that I talked about I think the
effects of nitrogen fertilization and
ozone pollution on terrestrial carbon
storage will become progressively less
important over the 21st century
especially the first half of the century
and I think by the second half
they will not be issues and the reason I
think this is that there are a whole
series of issues with either ozone
pollution or nitrogen pollution that are
going to begin to command the attention
of local and regional governments for
health for crop yields and for water
quality and I think they're going to be
addressed in time so I think over the
century they will become less important
as drivers and we might see in our
calculation a small net increase in
carbon storage as a result of a residual
nitrogen benefit land-use change I think
is clearly going to accelerate over the
next decades and lead to further
reductions in terrestrial carbon stocks
and I think that our challenge is to
figure out how to make the use of
agricultural lands more efficient I see
more efforts to we revegetate degraded
lands for the for the purposes of carbon
storage erosion control and climate
modification but in spite of these
worthy efforts my feeling is that we're
still going to lose about 50 to 100
petagrams associated with land-use
change over the century the bottom line
then is this small increase of carbon
storage in terrestrial ecosystems of
about a hundred petagrams the small
lancing could year to be diminished or
increased depending upon what happens
with those complexities and thresholds
and I guess one of our great concerns is
that one of those will become a dominant
feature of the carbon cycle and this
hundred petagrams sinc that we're
counting on for retirement is going to
disappear now if our goal is to maintain
or enhance our carbon style
what should we be doing I can't give you
very good answers but it seems to me we
need to work on changes in the ways we
use agricultural land this seems to me
critical we have to use it more
intensely that the existing lands more
intensely and we have to somehow figure
out how to reduce the biogeochemical
communications between the agricultural
lands and the surrounding landscape
I think reducing pollution will help
enhance carbon storage on land
especially the ozone pollution and it
will certainly have ancillary health and
environmental benefits and so in closing
I think that while our knowledge of the
global carbon cycle is incomplete we
know that our current approach to
managing the cycle is in the long term
not in the interests of humankind
finding better ways forward is essential
if we want to travel the path to
sustainability thank you
[Applause]
well the reading question the influence
of coal-fired power plants on the carbon
emissions associated with fossil fuels
there are probably experts in the room
who can answer this much better than I
I'm sure that it it's significant is it
at least 50% in the US some energy
expert in the partner
you know he was asking about coal-fired
power plants in particular
yeah we were interested though in a and
a number does anyone have one yeah
okay what's happening in China very
impressive but I was followed by the web
servers I think is missing the impact
instead a clock that number of papers by
so I can people like those meetings
saying particles to spend the atmosphere
of particular badness things out on me
has a significant
is that not
because I do think you're absolutely
right incident solar radiation is a
drive
it is inherently in the model because
the model is specifically parameterised
for each of the major vegetation types
which have soil pH gradients for example
the the temperate and boreal forests
tend to have fairly acidic soils in the
northern areas less acidic moving south
so yeah
you know but that's one of the that's
one of the the negative consequences of
nitrogen deposition in the long run
depending upon how nitrogen leaves that
system if it leaves us nitrate we have
problems
Days announced the oil was talking about
came over and joined this conversation
and gave some alternative perspectives
question maybe expand
other changes that were beginning to see
okay
the central point I was trying to make
with the palm oil is that you have
currently digicard forests that store
about 200 metric tons of carbon per
hectare in that massive would you
replace them with palm oil plantations
that store maybe 1/10 or less of the
carbon so just the very act having
nothing to do with whether it's palm oil
or not the very act of clearing the
forests and planting a much smaller
stature system has a tremendous impact
on the carbon cycle then the you know
that there are related questions that
one would want to think about in
planting some of these energy from
biomass crops and that is what else do
they require water nitrogen etc and the
environmental impacts could be quite
incredible I'm talking with a group in
Brazil now that the family owns 300,000
contiguous hectares in the Amazon basin
this is a vast land holding and they
have they want to sell the property they
have five bidders for the property and
the bidders are interested in making a
single biomass energy plantation the
land is divided into two parts there's a
plateau that is almost tableland an
escarpment and then some lowlands near a
river they're going to grow sugar cane
in the lowlands because they can
irrigate it and they're going to turn
the entire plateau into soybean
plantations for biodiesel and the
analysis is they could produce enough
energy to meet I think that figure was
and I may be wrong 1% of the
transportation energy needs of Brazil
from the
particular plantation so I think we're
gonna see a lot of that kind of activity
going on in it worries me greatly
because I think there may be tremendous
false carbon economies operating
well in New England we have a lot of
nitrogen fertilization going on as well
so it the balance is from a driver's
percent perspective not so clear we'd
have to look at you know which sites
we're talking about the other thing that
we want to remember about New England is
a lot of it is still in regrowing for us
having been cut over in the late 19th or
early 20th centuries and Woods Hole
where I lived if you look at a picture
of Woods Hole in about 1905 it is sheep
pasture and now you look at it and it's
entirely tree covered so this historical
land use and the legacy that it has left
us for carbon storage is really very
important to consider as well I think on
the whole the forests of New England are
still regrowing from the harvests of the
1920s and so I think they're acting as a
a sink and the sink could be stimulated
a little by carbon dioxide fertilization
and by nitrogen fertilization and the
temperature warming could reduce that
somewhat but but I don't think
significantly I think the one of the
other things to remember about these
carbon sinks is they fill up and
eventually you can't put any more forest
biomass in place space light competition
and so on become limiting so their pools
for a defined period of time and then
the best you can hope for is maintaining
them at the pool size that they have
attained at maximum
[Music]
that was a model run generated by the
MIT Global Change group that was John
correct me if I'm if he's still here I
don't you still here because you can you
can correct me is it a bit almost a
business as usual
[Music]
pre-industrial levels and the
Serkis already got three Celsius warming
and it seems that
last year a lot he started feeling
[Music]
I believe that already pull the drum the
transpire
oh sorry 10 to the 15th grams I'm sorry
I should have mentioned that at first
[Music]
sorry about that
we're billion metric tons
[Applause]
you